future hall-of-famer and I could say
that don't worry Steve and he's part of
the special eight and a half hour
edition of NFL gameday morning starting
at 9:00 a.m. on NFL Network a man who I
covered in his first Super Bowl with the
Carolina Panthers it was our first Super
Bowl ever at the NFL Network good to see
you Steve Smith how you doing good to
see you
yes JB yeah when was the first one you
did okay let's go back with your Phoenix
you're in Phoenix I wasn't finished
okay that's right so this is this this
is Bob I've seen four do the math baby
so you did the Super Bowl that's right
you did ride the horse by the way that's
not a metaphor for anything it literally
was a war it was a horse once I rode the
horse on that's right that's right with
those boots yeah yeah I had mad
difficults this is there's only one pair
these is happening match this belt I
don't know how many books do you own at
least 50 at least 50 50 and those my
cowboy boots but then I have my classy
boots than the ones over last night Oh
every man in that room one of my booth
last night for anything you actually
made notes I'm a jury Angelo was on last
night were you were you at midnight last
night Steve Smith you tapped out of that
last night just like me
okay what were you honestly did you get
a podium when you were in your Super
Bowl did you get a podium not it wasn't
as big as is this it was like we were in
a cafeteria just about yeah I mean the
game has changed you know Super Bowls
become a huge event it's really you have
people covering it from all over and you
know it used to be depending on the team
the coverage will go now it's whoever's
in the coverage is mega well yeah I'm
trying to remember what cuz we
definitely didn't cover it what media
day that's because we were just it was
we were 11 weeks
old it was like that the media Dave
probably had I think you had more people
in the audience than we had immediately
no kidding yeah it was in it we were in
it was in Houston yep and we're at the
dingy hotel and was that the name of it
no the fame the famous dingy suite of
hotels the hotel area that we were in in
Houston was considered guns point that's
what they the locals called okay and so
being from LA anything that the nickname
was guns point is generally area you
don't want to be so you were in the warm
embrace of the dingy hotel I mean it
wasn't dingy it just wasn't as nice as
the nowadays other host I what's crazy
is I went to I did I took my boy to to
the NC double-a finals Kimball Walker
was in that finals
you know Houston no kidding and guess
what hotel was only available the dingy
hotel that whole oh gosh yeah what else
do you remember about that Super Bowl um
will you recall one thing that was cool
is my boys are in my room when I was
packing they were helping me pack and my
our badges that we have now that I'm an
analyst I saved them all okay and so
it's pretty good because it has your
face and it has like the time year date
just all the schematics of it it's
really it's pretty remarkable that the
things they can put on that little pass
right in such graphic detail and I was
thinking about some how cool is talking
about the New England Patriots how they
are is um that first year that you guys
covered it yep um but 11 months old you
said we were 11 weeks of 11 weeks oh oh
infant infant if I was reading yes
indeed then that's a figure of speech a
figure of speech
yeah and so I thought it was cool you
talk about New England Patriots back in
2004 it was a 2004 a season yeah 2003 or
2004 calendar year yeah
the New England Patriots
from the AFC East we're playing a team
for an NSE South the year I retired
signed on NFL Network were in Houston
the NFC the AFC East is playing the NFC
South team what 10 12 years later right
same conferences one team's the same
another one some from the same division
quarterback coach is the same fruitiness
remarkable just tells you how long
they've been doing such a it's craziest
that I was on the job and so now have a
badge
from Super Bowl as analyst right and I
have some some articles of clothing and
other things from the ten years prior
mm-hmm same team but the same team is
play Wow
right so it's pretty cool just how much
they really are in in a Super Bowl how
much they they're they're postseason
play is remarked well that was our first
Super Bowl j.b smoove Steve Smith here
and they're rich as always our first
this is now NFL Network's 16th and it's
Brady and Belichick 8 of the 16 half of
the NFL Network covered Super Bowls have
been the Patriots and Brady and Belcher
and it's amazing that Super Bowl that
was just their second yeah
it was just there for it was their first
return trip to thee had no define
hairstyle or anything Brady Brady now
he's smooth and you know preaches L yeah
just pre anything every you just yeah
what's the TV one method you just did a
team effort
yeah and it's a you know on and it like
I said the longevity is something else
what do you think of the Rams chances in
this game Steve you know it's it's one
of those things when I'm looking at it
it could be one of those games I believe
that the Rams kind of give them they can
give them a problem because upfront
they're really good on the back end with
to leave they just makes that defense
different but they also have some of the
things that other teams they'll have
their else they the Rams have talent
like everybody has but they have a
pretty good technique and then they have
a
coach that puts them in great position
Shana Shaun McVeigh and I think Shaun
reveille is a younger version or has the
potential to be having this imprint on
this league the same way Bill Belichick
no kidding
just because when you look at Bill
Belichick I love Bill Belichick and what
he does just just from afar as opponent
and also as analysts like what he does
he's not one of those guys where he has
people around him he's the smartest guy
in the room he's in a room with a lot of
other smart people chiming they seem to
has done that as well I'm coach
Belichick is not the oldest he's not the
youngest he has a mixture it's not one
type of certain type of guy or or race
or whatever it's just multi right
multicultural multi age geographical
location just all of that and you look
at Shawn same exact thing when you talk
about when I really think about Bill
Belichick he's up there
I said with them Mount Rushmore of
coaches he has just changed the game of
football and what do you say currently
right now Bill Belichick is that guy who
when you go on his team just greatness
happens right with Tom Brady Tom Brady
affect Bill Belichick was chicken-or-egg
right it doesn't matter it's a root beer
float right root beer is awesome but now
the ice cream is go put them together
it's delicious so you have that and then
you have who's another guy you talked
about Vince Lombardi right what he's
done Tom floors then you go to Bill
Walsh right Chuck no like all these
coaches I'm saying when you look at
their pedigree and what they've done
right they have had their imprint on the
game the future the future of football
is only as bright as the past and that
those are the past and so that's who is
really Bill Belichick is really in and I
think Sean McVeigh has that opportunity
to be that next guy at age 33 in his
first Super Bowl just turned 33 also
Smith here along with JB smooth to his
left on the Rich Eisen show so I think
we've covered this before
and if we have then I apologize for
asking again did you have a chance to
play for the Patriots and yellow check
yeah it's a long story
well did you it just didn't work out or
did you with Bill or no he well first of
all I got a call from William Belichick
on my phone that's what the call
squilliam Belichick yes and so I said
you know you had that like you know
everybody's had that answer to call you
know you know well first of all your
grown man I'm in an airport and so you
know I'm in Airport heading to Baltimore
and I'm incognito I got sunglasses on my
hat had my hood on hello hey Steve it's
Bill and so he's talking to me and we
had a conversation and I he knew I was
going to Baltimore yet you already
verbally committed or dotted line signed
or what Baltimore yes well Baltimore
this is age but they faxed over an offer
sheet sure and three three or 14 fax
over offer she which is what I knew I
was getting on the plane for nothing
less than this yes so that was good
right and so we talked and right what
was interested in is I had to go back
because my oldest son was on a
recruiting trip it was a unofficial
recruiting trip to Northern Illinois
soccer team so I had to go catch a
flight to take him was our I was already
committed and so I told him we'll go
after that mmm but Baltimore was a nice
place and I really enjoy what they offer
me and you know people say well why
would you not go to New England when
Superbowl and all that stuff honestly
the what had transpired and where I was
at I just kind of wanted
just wanted to just kind of go my god
and and one of the things that you know
that coach Harbaugh told me which was
cool is that he said um you know if you
can't be yourself and at the time he
said it it just connected the dots for
me I was like man I want to be here he
said if you can't be yourself we don't
want you here we only want you to be
yourself and obviously you know when you
get removed from somewhere for being
yourself
right right you know you kind of don't
want to morph or change so I was like
I'm and he worked it out he at the coach
Harbaugh at that time wanted to move
Monday's to the day off so I was allowed
to fly home right after the game so we
Charlotte we're yeah well okay we play
Cleveland from Cleveland win lose or
draw was away game I flew from that city
from that city down it was a little FBO
and
in Monroe I flew there I got to go home
for way games so and I was off on Monday
so I would go back to work on Tuesday
sometimes not even to Wednesday so is
more of he allow it was convenience yeah
well I mean he can't be being with
family I mean there and pleading still
be able to continue your football career
right and and I don't know if he would
have gave me an opportunity but that's
just where I was and I enjoyed it and I
have fun so it's like no no I just
wanted people ask me that go they're
like oh how could you you know what
people when a Super Bowl is great right
haven't won it been been there gotten
close that same time man you want a
Super Bowl oosoo boat the cable bill is
still do right you know for some people
it changes their life a little bit you
still got bills you know you get other
perks but after a while those perks go
away and they go on to the next Super
Bowl champ
so yeah nothing can beat being home you
know and having Daddy there and kids in
the face it's interesting like when you
look down at your call waiting and saw
William Belichick you know I was doing
the combine as I always do for the NFL
Network last year and you know run my
40-yard dash on behalf of st. you
forerun rich run and i'm doing the the
combine mike Mayock now the general
manager the raiders to my right and i'm
looking down at the field and then all
of a sudden coming from my left shoulder
slapped down right in front of me on my
notes was a check a very nice check
written out to st. Jude and I'm like
where what is this and who is this and I
look at the top of the check and it says
William Bell a check on it and I thought
first thought was a who this woman and I
look up and see over my shoulder and see
the big smiling face of Bill Belichick
who came in to drop a cheque for st.
Jude you know which is a sigh again
another side of him that very rarely
easy here's a I tell you here's a as a
player you as a as opponent I really
didn't you really didn't like him right
you always kind of knew you had to be on
your A game playing them he wasn't gonna
talk to you is really gonna talk to you
but man just as an analyst now watching
it I it makes it easy for me like when
I'm watching their games there are so
many things I see and notice to pay
attention to and also work with you at
the draft it's talking to some of the
scouts what they do how they do it I
mean most most teams are scouting 200
225 a bad team to a really good team
really detailed 275 I'll talk to a
former scout who's been burnt out who's
moved on for the New England Patriots
they do about 350 scout 350 370 almost
over a hundred more individual players
well then all the 31 other teams and you
wonder why they are so good yeah because
they just get people just to play 10 or
12 plays throughout the year and that is
the difference yeah in a game between
going to the playoffs and not going and
not going to playoffs going to Super
Bowl I think the biggest thing this year
has been for the New England Patriots is
they statistically are not as good as
everyone else we used to see a New
England Patriots
lock up playoff spot by like week four
yeah right yeah you know that we deny
but now just differ statistically other
teams are catching up with them yeah and
so the word is that we've use on our
network is vulnerable they seem
vulnerable because everybody's starting
to seem like they're catching up
man the ability to change things up and
really throw a monkey wrench at
everybody's plans
you can't count them out and they so
they're scouting more than anybody else
and the collegiate ranks and then taking
somebody's third string of like Rex
Burkhead and beating you up and down
with people like him and Chris Hogan and
and James Develin right I mean it's it's
it's kind of crazy before I let you go
who do you think wins Steve I mean I
could say I think 2825 New England but I
can also see the Rams winning as well
just because they have made some
adjustments that we've never seen a team
make Kansas City than make them but the
Rams have made those adjustments and
they they have done in the middle of the
season after some losses that we
generally don't see an office of
dominant team make adjustments round of
applause for Steve Smith please good Jay
smooth here all three hours oh it's
great Steve always great to see you Matt
thank you we'll see you I will see you
at the shop at the NFL Network again the
pregame show started five minutes ago on
Super Sunday JB Smoove and also Brian
Billick still to come here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience